une production du studio SF
19e depuis longtemps c'est Barbade ouais
qui est très qui est très convo partout
c'est ainsi en fait très populaire qui
est très occupé donc on a parlé en fait
de tellement sujet avec elle c'était
tellement qu'on aurait pas pu
nécessairement s'attendre
qui a un background en fait en éducation
qui était prof de musique dans les
écoles primaires
maintenant fais plein de choses à faire
des lectures de compte pour les enfants
de la bibliothèque a fait bien sûr des
spectacles de drague donc à une émission
de télévision jeunesse aussi sur la
musique
que j'adore que je trouve vraiment
fabuleuse puis on a parlé bref du
système de d'éducation comment qu'on
peut l'améliorer on a parlé de l'ordre
du Drag c'est quoi c'est quoi les
éléments qui font que que qu'une drague
est une drague on a parlé de ces projets
à elle on a parlé
tellement de choses que je pense
qu'elles allaient découvrir un bon
beau personnage c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment intéressant quand on voit
lors du Drag vraiment comme une œuvre
une proposition artistique à plainte ou
même titre que n'importe quel autre type
d'or comme on fait la comparaison
beaucoup par le podcast avec les
humoristes puis de dire c'est pas parce
que tu vois une performance de drague
que tu aimes pas que nécessairement
tellement grand de l'offre puis une fois
que tu changes ton mais une fois que ton
esprit en vient à avoir ça vraiment
comme un
œuvre d'art en soi puis un numéro
artistique une proposition artistique ça
rend ça vraiment plus intéressant on
dirait puis ça permet de mieux
comprendre peut-être mais ouais le
phénomène parce que pour plusieurs
personnes puis moi le premier ça peut
paraître vraiment étrange parce qu'on
n'est pas exposé à ça plus jeune mais
c'était vraiment pas une culture que que
je connaissais puis que j'étais
exposé à
juste que puis on en parle dans le
podcast dans dernières années au Québec
puis partout en fait est vraiment plus
de de de reconnaissance puis de
visibilité mettons de la culture drague
dans les médias à cause de par exemple
les émissions comme RuPaul Drag Race
c'est pas comme ça puis au Québec et
coupe de
Gisèle le pas longtemps tu sais qu'ils
sont comme des deviner les célébrités au
Québec
drague puis justement c'est maintenant
je comprends vraiment en plus
à quel point c'est c'est c'est une forme
d'horreur à quel point c'est
probablement la forme d'or qui porte le
plus de chapeau c'est ce qu'on a pas
dans le podcast mais tu sais c'est
autant
la musique la danse
l'humour la confection des costumes du
maquillage la coiffure c'est tellement
multifacette que ça demande vraiment
beaucoup de talent vraiment on espère
vous allez aimer la conversion au temps
qu'on a aimé la voir puis sans plus
attendre on vous laisse l'écouter il
fait que mon podcast oui ben écoute le
podcast de cette semaine est présenté
par cosy cosy c'est quoi vous avez
peut-être vu passer les publicités sur
les réseaux sociaux cosy c'est des
divans des sofa qui viennent chez vous
en boîte dans déménager un divan d'un
appart à un autre
oui puis c'est un horreur c'est un
horreur parce que ça rentre jamais dans
le code de port non tu peux jamais le
défaire c'est lourd c'est pas
ergonomique ça traîne partout puis après
ça mais donc tu réussis à le dévisser
avec ton tadile plus tu dévisses les vis
peut-être chez vous les vis sont déjà
trouées il y a les filets sont brisés
pas moyen de remettre ton divan il se
défait tout crush moi je me souviens de
dernier déménagement qu'on a fait
ensemble puis c'était pire que n'importe
quel film d'horreur j'ai jamais vu un
pire même franchement c'était un
cauchemar cauchemar honnêtement c'était
le pire déménagement puis avec cosy vous
évitez ça parce que vous commandez moi
je l'ai fait hacker je parle
d'expérience tu commandes ton divan sur
le site web il y a toutes les
configurations qui peut avoir sur ton
dimanche choisis quelle configuration tu
vas avoir choisi quel coussin tu vas
avoir choisi tout ce que tu vas avoir le
divin le sofa arrive chez vous dans des
boîtes individuelles tous les boîtes tu
as besoin de 0 outils tu as pas besoin
d'utiliser zéro aussi il se monte tout
seul j'ai quand même un peu des gros
blocs Lego puis le résultat ça et le
sofa le plus confortable sur lequel tu
as pris combien de temps le monter le
monter ça m'a pris moins d'une heure
puis c'est un gros surface c'est
vraiment un gros chauffage c'est
vraiment simple les boîtes après tu mets
sur recyclage puis quand on va venir le
temps de déménager tu fais laverse ok tu
le défais sans outils c'est pas non pas
de vis rien tu l'amènes pièce par pièce
dans le truc de management tu leur
construis au bord c'est c'est incroyable
moi c'est un service absolument
incroyable si vous êtes dans le marché
pour un sofa même si vous n'êtes pas je
vous créez un besoin en ce moment c'est
de la grosse bombe honnêtement honnête
c'est ça mon opinion c'est vraiment le
fun puis je vous conseille d'y aller il
fait caler voir sur cosy point ca puis
ça va vous ça va vous changer votre vie
le podcast est présenté par nos amis
chez manscape manscape on en parle
tellement souvent on en parle
littéralement à chaque podcast parce que
parce que on adore les produits parce
que de toute évidence vous aussi vous
adorez les produits parce que on a un
excellent retour de son temps de
collaboration on fait qu'on continue
comme ça même Skype c'est des produits
pour l'entretien
de ta peau de ta pilosité de tes cheveux
de ton poil en fait de tout c'est un
vraiment 3,60 puis là aussi de
prédilection c'est le landmore le
landmore c'est un Clipper qui a et
onepluie premièrement ce qui est
l'aspect principal qui est qui a une
technologie qui t'empêche de [ __ ] les
bases c'est vraiment un Clipper
ultime pour tout ce soit en dessous de
la ceinture ta face d'homme chez toi tu
es un
que je trouve qu'il va vraiment vraiment
bien puis les produits
comme le parfum shampoing body wash le
parfum je le dis souvent le mais je
reçois des commentaires quand je le mets
j'ai même pas je le mets juste quand je
sors quand je vois dans une petite
soirée là quand vient le temps d'aller
de becs à des amis que tu vois
actuellement tu sens bon mais c'est
magnifique
c'est magnifique puis on a un code promo
pour vous ils ont une multitude de
paquets de toutes sortes avec toutes
leurs produits vous pouvez aller voir
tout ça sur leur site web mais
assurez-vous utiliser le code promo sans
filtre parce que vous allez avoir 20 %
label vous allez avoir le shopping
gratuit puis les autres ils vont savoir
que c'est nous qui vous envoie ça ça
nous aide ça ça nous aide beaucoup ça
encourage beaucoup le podcast fake
continuer comme ça continuer à
encourager même Skype contenant de vous
encourager et puis offrez-vous le cadeau
tu débarrasses propres
surtout merci
Salut je prends un petit instant pour
parler de nouveau projet sur lequel on
travaille au sud-ouestf depuis un petit
bout de jeu c'est une composition cube
radio et sud-ouestf ça s'appelle post
mortem et c'est avec nul autre que la
reine du trouble Victor et donc le
podcast en fait ça penche sur un dossier
de meurtre irrésolu qui est survenu dans
les années 80 une dénommée Roxane luxe
qui s'est fait assassiné et puis on fait
une petite enquête là dessus on essaie
de découvrir qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
et on se rend compte que vraiment plein
d'affaires étranges qui s'est passé
autour de ce Cola alors l'épisode 1 est
déjà disponible partout allez écouter ça
et je vous laisse avec la bande-annonce
du projet
[Musique]
Sud Radio
le premier avril 1981 vers 23h30
Roxane reçoit 70 coups de bâton dans
plusieurs au visage
[Musique]
un prénom sourire le
thé le frère de Roxane tombe sur une
scène d'horreur elle est défigurée
40 ans plus tard le coupable court
toujours
quand j'ai rencontré Stéphane son
histoire me touchait il y avait 13 ans
quand sa mère a été assassinée
et autrice maquette à moi c'est qu'on
puisse aider les familles à obtenir des
réponses sur des cas de meurtre ou de
disparition
Stéphane même 40 ans plus tard cherchant
encore celui qui lui a arraché sa mère
[Musique]
il y a certains indices qui auraient pu
être très précieux qui sont souillés
ça fait 16 ans que j'attaque moi j'ai
répondu ça fait 16 ans qu'on dit que tu
es ma mère
que je vais me rendre compte si tu as
beaucoup d'éléments étranges dans ce
dossier là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là ben merci à vous de me
recevoir salut
merci je suis content ça fait ça un bout
de quantité je me suis dit là ça va être
le fun d'être de l'autre côté la table
plutôt que d'être
l'invité plutôt que
avec PL au camping
c'était quand même c'était sur réel
c'est ce moment-là je m'en allais avec
ma sœur à Québec plus je faisais on va
faire juste un petit arrêt comme ça
m'attendre
c'est vraiment le comble je sais pas
comment dire ça de
le compte du genre de camping ces gens
on a un petit espace c'est pas gros
faisons un camping parce que il y a rien
d'autre
pas assez de la ville pour faire comme a
vraiment je décroche parce que en plus
de toute la 136
comme ça j'étais dans un autre rôle
j'étais plus dans le rôle de TPL c'était
vraiment son podcast moi j'étais dans le
rôle de l'espèce de je peux dire Beach
je service le c'est pas un bon terme
mais tu sais bon je suis un peu non
challenge puis un peu comme un peu le
rôle du Fou du Roi à tout mon ensemble
en version pimp
[Musique]
ton expérience de force
tous les projets que je fais avec PL à
la date j'aime bien mes sols le prochain
projet ce serait peut-être d'aller le
rejoindre au Mexique les résultats rendu
compte
c'est vrai
il a décidé de retourner au Mexique
dans le sud
[Rires]
du coréens c'est comme ben oui ça va me
tentez pas de problème moi je vous
comprends que je suis du genre à dire
oui à tout honnêtement là dans ma vie
80 je vais dire 18% des choses qui m'ont
été proposées j'ai dit oui des choses
qui étaient le fun d'autres choses qui
étaient moins fort
mais honnêtement je dis oui à tout quand
tu m'as proposé on se rend compte du
tout ça j'avais aucune idée qui j'allais
rencontrer puis j'ai dit oui alors quand
je savais devant le Marc-André Grondin
j'ai fait trop bon
je prends un petit temps mais le projet
mon dieu il était très très
emprisonnaire à ce moment-là on était
vraiment pas du tout au même stade on a
même pas l'idée de musique c'est plus
sur le compte parce que lui il avait vu
dans un heure du compte que je fais on
va en parler genre on en reparle puis
d'ailleurs j'en viens d'en faire une le
c'est pour ça que le matin exactement
puis
il m'a vu à la Grande Bibliothèque en
2017 à cette heure du compte là il est
venu avec sa fille et puis il faudrait
que je t'écris mes cris on s'est
rencontrés avec
une de ses amis qui est scénariste mais
comme je dis la ligne comprenait était
pas du tout du tout la même que le le
produit fini on était complètement
ailleurs on était plus dans le conte ou
toute seule on a même fait des espèces
de petits pilotes où je racontais une
histoire pour voir ce que ce serait la
bonne formule qu'est-ce qu'on puisse
finalement à adjoindre aussi bon une
boîte de prod faire plaisir et puis
toutes les gens autour ben le projet
migrer mais pas maigri mais juste
évoluer pour en arriver plus à combiner
la musique que lui c'est un très grand
mélaman oui peut-être que quand vous
êtes rendu compte que les deux vous
tripier s'amusaient que ça comme ça
il y a beaucoup de ça aussi que c'est
fait sans ma présence nécessairement
dans le sens que des fois j'avais pas de
nouvelles pendant 4 5 6 mois c'est mort
dans l'oeuf c'est parce que je veux dire
probablement
bien un autre alors des idées des gens
qui ont des idées puis que qui vont pas
jusqu'au bout de leur idée ou qui se
font dire non puis qui arrête là parce
qu'ils ont eu un homme parce que des
noms tu vas en avoir mais en bout de
ligne ça te prend un oui c'est tout
simplement
parmi toutes les noms tu vas avoir mais
que ça migré ça fait ça ça se
transformer il y a eu des mois où
j'avais aucune nouvelle je me dis bon
c'est mort dans l'œuf et puis finalement
non il me revenait en disant depuis chez
le place en bout de ligne finalement
tout point TV puis 10 belles émissions
je suis donc je suis particulièrement
particulièrement friand vraiment puis je
pense que tout le monde qui a travaillé
sur le projet le fait vraiment
parce qu'il croyait vraiment parce qu'il
voulait quelque chose de beau souvent
même aussi
je veux parler de cachette
nécessairement mais tout le monde tout
le monde est donné c'est du sien pour
faire en sorte que ça fonctionne
qu'on n'est pas les heures puis vraiment
vraiment ça a vraiment été super
au point que c'est comme un en
contrepartie justement on a donné
quelque chose de tellement de bonnes
qualités que là si on voulait d'une
saison 2 fois coté ça puis il faut à
côté les coûts aussi fait explo tout le
monde qui est nécessairement prêt à
engager avec ce budget
le fameux système de limonade dans des
offices
c'est comme ta mère te donne 10 dollar
pour aller acheter un stand de limonade
puis là ça coûte juste 9$ mais si tu le
dis à ta mère la prochaine fois ça va te
donner 9 dollars exactement
faut jamais en faire plus que le client
jamais
de passion tu sais tout le monde est
trop craqué puis là c'est des esprits
craintés
engagé dans un projet ça donne toujours
la meilleure affaire
après ça c'est de jouer avec la balance
comme d'avoir du monde craqué avec une
effervescence de création
je me dis si c'est pas ça il y aura
d'autres choses puis à nouveau mais je
veux dire Oui puis si elle m'a donné il
y a plus rien mais il y aura plus rien
puis je vais retourner à l'enseignement
c'est tout
c'est là dedans j'ai étudié j'ai étudié
en enseignement de la musique j'ai mon
bac à de Lucas
même si je dois vous avouer que Lucas
bon j'ai pas toujours toujours étudié
fort fort
c'est
aussi un peu le parcours de beaucoup de
monde qui font des études en or c'est
que moi
fort toute mon parcours pour être
franche j'avoue j'en ai appris beaucoup
plus sur le terrain une fois j'ai
commencé à enseigner que que dans sur
les bancs à l'université les ventes
universitaire parce que
je dirais que la formation est peut-être
pas particulièrement bien adapté puis en
ce moment on parle beaucoup beaucoup de
pénuries de mes 9 partout forcément mais
ça fait quand même un bout bien avant la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre généralisée on
parlait de pénurie d'enseignante et
d'enseignants et je le vois parce que
les raisons pour ça c'est écrit gros
comme le ciel de gros
comme le mec
mais c'est écrit dans le ciel que cette
pénurie là
allez arriver puis elle est là parce que
on donne pas la bonne on a pas une
formation adaptée aux enseignants puis
aux enseignants tu sais c'est un métier
qui est très qui est relativement
technique dans le sens que surtout McDon
enseigne je parle plus mettons primaire
secondaire
en général vraiment c'est un métier qui
est relativement technique c'est en
apprend beaucoup en le faisant tu sais
c'est pas nécessairement tu es pas dans
les les grosses affaires de philosophie
ou quoi que ce soit c'est les profs qui
visent à aller enseigner justement
l'université parfaite je peux comprendre
une plus dans le théorie qu'on est plus
dans dans des concepts dans des choses
comme ça mais quand enseigne au primaire
tu es dans du concret dans de l'action
si Jérémy qui comprend pas
faut que tu expliques ou si je n'aime
pas c'est pas ta généreux marchera pas
c'est pas ça les grosses problématiques
les gens pensent que ah mais c'est
difficile à cause que à cause des élèves
qui comprennent pas puis ou whatever
c'est tellement pas ça on est
complètement ailleurs on est beaucoup
dans la sur tâche dans toutes les tâches
qui qui nous sont pas montrés justement
à l'université
mettons que je compare avec une
infirmière une infirmière a fait une
technique parce que tout ce qu'elle va
avoir à faire c'est très technique les
gestes techniques c'est sûr qu'il y a
des connaissances à avoir mon épaule
dans les on n'est pas dans les hautes
connaissances philosophiques ou quoi que
ce soit on est dans beaucoup dans
l'action vous savez beaucoup dans je
veux pas évidemment vulgariser puis
simplifier puis que mettez dans des
choses concrètes bref c'est des piqûres
des des médicaments etc
l'enseignement est similaire à ça mais
la formation est très différente la
formation est universitaire et elle est
très très
des fois du pelletage de nuages un peu
ou des choses qui sont beaucoup trop
poussées pour ce qu'on va faire
réellement si moi je le savais que ça
serait vers le primaire ou le secondaire
je sais que j'irai pas au sujet pour
l'université je le savais d'entrée de
jeu mais j'ai eu des cours de
d'analyse musicale puis plusieurs cours
d'analyse musicale pas juste un de trois
crédits plusieurs 1 le 2 le 3 c'est fait
qui suivent sur ce plusieurs années
plusieurs sessions
jamais jamais c'est drôle parce que
pendant la pandémie je vais être un
ménage dans mes notes de cours aussi que
j'avais gardé toutes ces années là je me
disais je regardais je me dis mais je
peux pas croire que j'ai perdu du temps
à faire ça alors qu'on aurait pu
m'expliquer justement Jérémy le camp tu
fais une crise que c'est ça quand tu
parles le contrôle dans ta classe parce
que le lendemain c'est une journée
pédagogique ou c'est le lendemain de
l'Halloween puis tout le monde est
boosté sur le sucre comme des gens qui
arrivent dans
exactement ça que j'avais besoin de mal
à mâchoire autant que quelqu'un qui a
pris de la daube oui
[Rires]
c'est exactement ça tu as besoin de
savoir ça tu as pas besoin que ton
besoin qu'on prend 5 ces choses là
en musique interrogation puis le tronc
commun je pense là interprétation ou de
tu veux être un interprète
instrumentiste versus enseignement le
tronc commun est quand même très commun
il y a une coupe différente qui sont
complètement différents
c'est pour ça aussi que beaucoup de
pieds là on parle évidemment de
l'enseignement de la musique parce que
bon on parlait des choses qu'on connaît
mais je le sais pour avoir parlé à plein
d'autres membres aussi que les
formations dans d'autres domaines via
diriger vers l'enseignement c'est le
même problème aussi c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de grands principes on
est beaucoup dans les études très très
théorique puis tu as pas de concret tu
as pas de chance concrètes c'est pas
adapté à ce que tu vas réellement faire
sur le terrain tu sais que tu en
apprends beaucoup plus dans tes stages
tout ça des stages qui arrivent à la
relativement à la fin c'est en un à
chaque année de ces quatre bacs qui
apprend le bac puis le premier là c'est
un stage genre tu mets le gros orteil
dans l'eau puis c'est tout petit en bas
c'est fait de rien cesser c'est 5 jours
d'observation on n'a pas le temps de
faire rien 5 jours le petit prend pas de
charge rien n'utilise juste t'observes
qui se passe juste pour dire oublie pas
tu étais dans une école secondaire avant
là c'est juste pour te ramener un peu
quand tu étais au secondaire c'est
vraiment juste ça puis là après la
deuxième année alors que ça fait deux
ans d'études là tu as un premier stage
pas ta prof d'université parce que en
bout de ligne quand tu es devant ta
classe
de toutes les choses à gérer tu as le
message en intercom qui te bouffe 5
minutes au début de la de ta période
mais c'était ça planification et
aux minutes près ben ça vient juste
d'être fâché juste à cause de ça tu
comprends avec il y a plein de grands
principes universitaires qui sont pas
adaptés puisqu'il fait en sorte que les
étudiants sortent de l'université avec
un bac parfait mais aucune expérience ou
presque et qui après 5 ans font comme ok
là j'ai vu c'est dans les cinq premières
années font comme ben non c'est pas du
tout ça pour me préparer c'est pas ça
que je m'attendais puis ben il quitte
puis là on a une pénurie je veux dire
c'est clair comme l'orage puis quand tu
réussis à garder après les seins les
cinq premières années les gens que tu
réussis à garder ben là on les épuise on
les tort puis on est au max ce qui fait
que ou des fois comme c'est le cas pour
moi par exemple
de l'espèce de bureaucratie tellement
lourde qui fait que
les enseignants sont souvent comme des
numéros plutôt que des personnes qui ont
des réalités tout un peu différentes
mais dans les feux comme mission
scolaires les centres de service
scolaire il y a la bureaucratie grosse
comme le broc qui fait que
le numéro puis peut-être pas je parle
pour moi par exemple quand je suis
arrivé ça faisait 16 ans que
j'enseignais puis quand je suis arrivé
pour dire à ma direction écoute là j'ai
un projet que je peux pas refuser c'est
un mois de tournage c'est juste un mois
j'attends partielle si j'enseigne un
temps partiel fait en bout de ligne ce
que je te demande c'est 11 jours de
m'absenter je te demande de m'absenter
pendant 11 jours oui c'est sur un mois
mais comme j'entends partiel c'est
l'équivalent de 11 jours
[Musique]
de toutes les autres écoles que j'ai
fait de toutes les autres directions
scolaire dit ben je suis désolé on peut
pas parce que les enseignants
ce genre de me demande là c'est tout
c'est moi je demande parce que
exactement parce que voilà puis parce
que ça tombe dans une craque puis après
de revenir à la charge pour dire
garde-le moi j'ai vu tous les élèves
toute l'année
je m'absente au mois de mai je vais
revenir à la je m'absente type comme je
dis l'équivalent à 11 jours 4 cours
parce que j'ai un cours par semaine avec
les autres fait que quatre fois puis je
reviens en juin pour clore l'année avec
eux faire les bulletins etc etc puis
après l'année d'après je vais être de
retour etc
mais au lieu de ça il me font ben non on
n'a pas le personnel pour remplacer on
peut pas Acquier ça ce genre de demande
fait plutôt perdre quelqu'un un prof
pendant un mois tu le perds à vie au
final parce que les autres prennent le
pari tu vas rester mais je veux dire des
affaires comme ça c'est comme je suis
désolé mais
ça c'est un copains
c'est pas tout le monde qui s'en va
faire des émissions de drague je
comprends très bien mais il reste qu'il
y a plein de gens puis encore plus
aujourd'hui qui doivent concilier plein
d'affaires dans leur vie aussi qui sont
pas nécessairement à la vocation de
l'enseignement juste l'enseignement mais
que
c'est pas évident quand tu moi je sais
que ça m'est arrivé à 30 ans de dire
aïeul j'ai 30 ans je suis devant ma
classe puis je t'avoue que c'est une
journée qui fonctionne pas tant de dire
il m'en reste encore 30 points à faire
dans la même je pourrais rester dans
cette classe là à faire la même affaire
avoir les élèves passer d'une année à
l'autre tu sais puis grandir les
premières 2e 3e 4e la sixième etc mais
restez là parce qu'il y a pas
nécessairement d'avancement dans
l'enseignement dans le sens que c'est
beaucoup de gens dira mais tu pourrais
devenir direction des commissaires
direction c'est une autre t'es pas
nécessaire
des budgets tu gères des des parents qui
sont en colère tu gères à mentir tu es
complètement ailleurs on n'est pas du
tout du tout dans l'enseignement si toi
ça tente de pousser ça un peu plus loin
il y a peu de possibilités
du terrain en disant un peu qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour améliorer
l'éducation amusée il y en a qui se
dirigent vers ça c'est vrai mais
effectivement c'est en tout cas bref
attendant de parler on dirait
enseignant c'est un peu une vocation là
tu sais puis on dirait que comme
je sens pas la passion
ultime pour pour l'enseignement parce
que est-ce que tu l'avais est-ce que tu
l'as perdu est-ce que tu l'as encore
est-ce que où est-ce que voir la passion
pour l'enseignement j'ai la passion pour
l'enseignement mais peut-être pas
nécessairement dans ce dans ces cas-là
toujours nécessairement mais je
retournerai en enseignement écoute
j'étais passionné là je faisais des
spectacles je faisais des heures je
fournissais des la quantité de milliers
de dollars que j'ai dépensé de ma poche
parce que je me suis dit ok maintenant
je veux faire ce projet-là puis je sais
que ça coûte ça mais je sais qu'on a pas
l'argent enfin je ne l'éponge ma classe
comme je le veux j'ai pas le budget pas
grave
bien sûr que j'avais la vocation mais ça
en même temps c'est tantôt on parlait
des budgets tout ça puis c'est un peu
l'affaire de l'animalade que tu disais
c'est le même problème avec les profs si
les profs se disent aïe tu me payes pour
35 heures c'était 32 mais 32 heures tu
me payes pour 32 heures je vais faire
mon 32 heures mais je vais en faire bain
plus où je vais être tellement comme à
la maison je vais faire plein d'overtime
après les gens les sa tendances
donc
la question de dire oui je pense que il
y a des gens qui ont cet appel là puis
que c'est vraiment comme les jeunes
transmettent et puis oui c'est une
vocation mais de dire tu sais que
mettons les gars qui est électricien
puis tu dis pas l'électricien c'est une
vocation fait le pour des conditions
plus tôt puis pour telle salaire pas
parce que c'est déjà un appel à faire ça
qui croit vraiment qu'il devrait pas
être
qui était fait par les religieuses
beaucoup qui justement avait cette
vocation là cet appel là puis bien si
c'est encore resté un peu ancré mais
faut se détacher de ça là faut se
détacher parce que sinon effectivement
on a un système d'éducation qui va aller
tout proche parce que ça part beaucoup
beaucoup des enseignants et des
enseignants l'éducation c'est évident
alors
voilà on va taguer les ministres de
l'éducation sur ce podcast
de lui ou elle on sait même pas à ça
on sait pas encore mais
puis en plus ministre d'éducation
d'avant qui était un prof aussi dans de
la même commission scolaire où
j'enseigne le même centre de ça parce
que là vous enseignez d'ailleurs
si tu dis ok il me semble il y a du voir
ces choses là il y a du
ça ça donne ce que ça donne en ce moment
effectivement voilà mais écoute on
pourra parler longtemps moi ça me
passionne ce sujet-là parce que je parle
pas de beaucoup de sujets dont j'essaie
de pas parler de sujets dont je connais
peu mais ça je le connais bien
je le connais parce que je l'ai vécu une
différence entre connaître quelque chose
puis le vif et que quand tu l'as vécu tu
as été de date vu la réalité de vu ce
qui se passe quasiment ce qui marche
moins aussi tu as vu les élèves qui
[Musique]
de vu les élèves qui à la fin sortent du
primaire donne ça comme primaire
le 11 ans
honnêtement
te bâti une bonne partie des fondations
parce que
ils disent que souvent comme un groupe
de personnes le quotient intellectuel
des enfants de 12 ans puis honnêtement
quand il les regarde interagir un groupe
de personnes qui a pas de structure
nécessairement puis tu réalises
qu'effectivement c'est des enfants de 12
ans
tu dis ça c'est le portrait de notre
futur génération pas mal là oui
évidemment au secondaire
mais ce qu'ils ont acquis comme valeur
puis comme base comme fondation c'est à
la fin du primaire que c'est là il y a
des choses qui peuvent changer mais ça
prend beaucoup de choses pour changer
des choses parce que là ça a été ancré
fait que tu les habitudes tôt à être
ouvert à la différence avec toutes ces
valeurs là ça se passe pas au secondaire
ça se passe au primaire puis moi je leur
ai parlé dans certaines mécos et c'est
un des gros avantages d'avoir des cours
d'art moi j'appelle tout ça des cours
d'or plus que des cours de musique c'est
de pouvoir parler de plein de sujets qui
sont même un peu avant-gardiste d'amener
d'utiliser l'art pour amener plein de
sujets puis moi je leur ai parlé
d'environnement je leur ai parlé aussi
d'alcool dans un de mes projets qu'on a
fait
amener je vous le résume mais bref on
avait un sujet où on navigue à travers
les couleurs
puis quand on était rendu dans le bloc
jaune qui était le bloc du plaisir dans
l'histoire qu'on faisait dans le
spectacle qu'on montait ben justement je
parlais du plaisir puis comment on en
arrive à avoir du plaisir on peut avoir
du plaisir dans la vie de tous les jours
mais des gens qui parfois c'est
utilisent des substances pour avoir du
plaisir j'ai pas mentionné les drogues
mais j'ai parlé de l'alcool qu'est-ce
que ça fait l'alcool ben c'est que ça te
crée un faux plaisir c'est que ton
balancier là qui va de gauche à droite
du plaisir au moins plaisir ou tu sais
qui continuellement balance comme ça là
tu vas artificiellement tirer du côté
plaisir puis
tu peux pas continuer à boire tout le
temps il faut que tu larges faut que tu
sois presque revienne l'autre côté mais
il y a des gens qui sont pas prêts bref
je vous le résume super vite mais si je
parle
j'ai jamais dans ce cours-là jamais eu
la tension des élèves autant alors qu'il
y a plein de parents qui peut-être
écoutent en ce moment même qui disent
mais non mais on peut pas parler à des
enfants de 11 ans 12 ans d'alcool oui
mais oui mais avec des mots enfin c'est
la même chose avec la sexualité aussi
j'avais beaucoup de parents qui sont
réticents à parler de sexualité mais ta
sexualité d'adulte qui a vécu toutes les
choses que tu as vécues ça c'est ta
vision la sexualité
replace-toi comme un enfant de 12 ans ou
de 11 ans ou de 10 ans c'est quoi sa
sexualité à lui c'est pas genre tu sais
un peu tu comprends c'est pas faire des
félins
[Rires]
ça prenait pour en parler
mais bref c'est pas ça la parler de
sexualité à un jeune parler de sexualité
un jeune c'est parler d'acceptation
parler de compréhension de parler de
dire à 11 ans le tendresse le doute ta
mère en t'imaginant que c'est ton ami
que tu connais petit fermant les yeux
parce que jamais connu ça embrasser
quelqu'un c'est ça là la sexualité pour
un jeune de 12 ans ça se passe pas
nécessairement avoir des culottes ça se
passe beaucoup dans la tête avec parlons
de parlons de consentement à ces jeunes
là c'est là que ça commence tu sais
et pourtant on est tellement réticents à
parler de de ces sujets là
quand je leur ai parlé d'alcool à mes
jeunes je leur ai dit vous vous avez 11
ans 12 ans en ce moment
quelques semaines auparavant il y a une
jeune fille qui s'appelait Athéna
Gervais qui était une jeune de 14 ans
qui est morte à cause de consommation
des fours locaux espèces de boisson
alcoolisée à 11.9% d'alcool ça peut être
vendu les épiceries parce que d'eau
c'est juste à la SAQ tu vois toutes les
gros affaires
ben moi j'ai dit cette jeune lol avec 14
ans c'est vous dans deux ans là pas dans
8 9 10 ans là dans deux ans je leur ai
dit moi je suis désolé là
je me semble que j'aurais passé à côté
de la traque je sais pas comment je me
sentirais si je voyais votre face sur le
journal
c'est à la Une journal dans deux ans
parce que vous êtes décédé c'est parce
que vous êtes oui je leur ai dit ça puis
je te dis je suis quand je leur ai dit
là
j'ai dit la journée là
ou parce que ça va arriver pas si la
journée quand on va te proposer un verre
quand on va dire tiens prends un verre
ben j'aimerais ça que tu deviennes de
laduction qu'on a en ce moment
j'aimerais ça que tu viennes de du
balancier j'aimerais que tu te
souviennes de dire toi intérieurment
est-ce que tu te sens prêt à dire oui
pas parce que tu vas être l'ami de
l'autre pas parce que l'autre tu mets de
la pression parce que toi tu te sens
prêt puis tu as le droit de dire je le
sais pas tu as le droit tu es même pas
obligé de dire oui ou non tu peux dire
écoute je le sais pas encore si je suis
prêt laisse-moi le temps de réfléchir
c'est tout c'est tout puis la perpétie
toi éventuellement tu es la personne qui
l'offre là ce verre de bière là où cette
bière là où c'est peu importe ce fort
locaux
respecte la décision de la personne
aussi c'est insiste pas à dire je suis
pas sûr parfait t'es pas moins plus mon
ami tu es pas moins hâte ou plus haute
passe au contrat je veux que tu prennes
tu m'as dit que tu voulais prendre le
temps prends le temps tu m'as dit non je
respecte ton nom j'insiste pas c'est fun
dans la langue française là on a un nom
puis un oui même si tu entends pas là
même si tu es dans un de la musique est
forte tu peux le savoir que la personne
a te dit non parce que ça fasse ça c'est
exagère je mets des jeunes collants pour
que ça soit
alors c'est seul c'est de ça qu'il faut
parler aussi là
c'est tellement ça fait ça fait une
chance que ça fait vraiment du sens que
tu dis parce que
il faut que tu en ailles parler avant
que la situation se présente puis
de mon expérience à moi je consomme plus
d'alcool
il y a des gros et des graves mais de ma
perspective à moi je veux dire j'ai je
me suis fait offrir de l'alcool avant de
me faire dire avant que je discute avec
des gens plus vieux de comment réagir se
faisait offrir de l'alcool mais c'était
pas de façon
perverse ou malicieuse là mais c'était
juste que j'en avais jamais entendu
parler la première fois que je vire une
broche je m'en rappelle encore puis
si j'avais été mis au courant que ça
pouvait déraper comme ça promet je
préfère un petit peu plus attention
comme ça se peut que tu aurais pas fait
de plus attention mais tu aurais été
conscient de dire de qu'est-ce qui se
passe je l'assume en ce moment que je
prends une brosse pour que ça va puis
que mon pendule il va revenir de l'autre
bar aussi
puis je le tire artificiellement mais
Watchers quand tu vas revenir de l'autre
bar on va pas gagner un
faut que tu l'assumes faut que tu sois
prêt puis si il y a personne qui te le
dis cette personne qui te le montrer
personne qui te l'a appris ben c'est ça
tu la prends de me faut arrêter de jouer
à l'autruche le petit imaginer que les
jeunes n'y en voit pas la sexualité
faut leur enseigner il faut couper il
faut couper l'herbe sur le pied à toutes
ces choses qui vont voir sur internet à
toutes ces mauvaises façons d'amener ça
on peut parler de tous les sujets avec
les gens mais en leur parlant à leur
niveau puis l'internet c'est pas ça qui
a fait alors
niveau fait que les autres y essaient de
comprendre alors que plein de choses que
tu as pas tu es pas encore apprises
essaie de comprendre des sujets qui qui
leur sont montrés la sexualité qui leur
est montré où les femmes se font traiter
comme la merde puis or il y a une dent
ça non non non là est-ce que tu vois
c'est pas la réalité et puis
voilà puis après ça demande pourquoi les
jeunes garçons il insistent quand une
femme leur dit non une fille comprenez
ce que je veux dire c'est ça il faut
couper l'herbe sur pied à toute ça pour
pouvoir
pour pouvoir les préparer à ce qui s'en
vient plus tard puis c'est entre pour ça
que je fais les arts du compte aussi
pour les préparer à
dans nous là on pense qu'on est
diversifié mais whatchaout dans une
génération ou dans 10 ans il va y en
avoir encore plus de diversité on va les
élargir je parle même pas diversité
sexuelle je parle de toutes les
diversités qui existent
il y a énormément on s'ouvre beaucoup à
l'immigration et je pense que c'est une
très bonne chose mais il faut préparer
aussi les gens à être capable de comment
tu réagis lorsque quelque chose est
différent tu sais faut pas que tu te
fermes faut pas que tu dises c'est
différent je déteste ça c'est ça me fait
peur c'est faut pas que tu tombes dans
cette peur là faut que tu gardes ta
vigilance c'est sûr ça c'est parfait
mais il faut que tu restes ouvert à je
vais prendre il faut que je prenne le
temps il faut que je me force à prendre
le temps parce que les préjugés vont
embarquer rapidement c'est sûr c'est
naturel c'est des instincts animaux tu
sais quand un animal qui est dans la
nature
une fraction de seconde pour décider si
la chose qui voit à veulent manger ou il
va le manger tu comprends ce que je veux
dire c'est un danger ou c'est pas un
danger mais c'est naturel qu'on fasse ça
mais nous en tant qu'humain on peut
prendre le temps aussi de dire ok ça a
clairement pas l'air de menacer lui il
est pas en train de me menacer avec un
couteau un fusil bon je vais prendre le
temps d'écouter je vais voir ça se peut
que je sois pas d'accord mais ça se peut
que je réalise aussi que finalement il y
a beaucoup de choses en commun qu'on a
puis que nos différences elles sont pas
si grandes que ça c'est alors qu'elle
paraissait immense à première vue c'est
j'arrive quand j'arrive devant quelqu'un
c'est clair que les gens ils voient
quelque chose qui est très différent qui
est coloré qui est la peau noire en plus
dans mon cas qui est une fille mais qui
est un homme mais c'est pas un
mélangeant pour des gens
prenez le temps faites juste d’asseoir
prenez le temps pas des heures juste
quelques minutes pour comprendre
qu'est-ce que cette personne me fait
qu'est-ce que ce personnage pour c'est
quoi ces motivations à faire ça aussi
puis finalement vous allez rencontrer
que vous avez bien les choses en commun
puis que les petites différences oui ils
peuvent être ils peuvent vous titiller
mais que en bout de ligne c'est pas
là-dessus qu'on devrait accorder de
l'importance quand tu abordes
j'imagine que c'était pas toujours
justement au plan de cours officiel
mettons là
je faisais un plan je me faisais un plan
oui tout à fait je l'ai préparé là je
vous en parle comme ça sur le fly mais
c'est pas quelque chose que je me dis
c'est quoi demain je dois parle d'alcool
non j'ai préparé ça des semaines avant
aussi tu sais j'ai fait un powerpoint
même où j'ai justement montré le pendule
j'allais aussi aller chercher tu sais
les
mais on les quantités d'alcool qu'il y a
dans un verre aussi c'est pour leur
montrer là quand vous avez votre boisson
faut un local
la quantité d'alcool que vous avez
là-dedans c'est pas juste une petite
consommation là puis vous pouvez ça ou
complètement
le décalage on parlait de décalage entre
mettons ce que tu vas prendre à
l'université puis vraiment le terrain je
vais me casser des choses que tu as que
tu es magnifique et ton programme ce que
tu as vu qu'il y avait un besoin de vu
que mais quand tu fais ça est-ce que des
fois ce que se termine est censé
enseigner la musique beaucoup de parler
de ça
ou si jamais vraiment arrivé mettons
parce que j'ai quand même si je pense
j'ai fait mes profs puis les les
directions en mettant les directions
viennent pas se mêler de tout tout tout
tout tout
ils nous font confiance et tant mieux
ils font confiance aux enseignantes et
aux enseignants ça c'est tant mieux mais
si ça aurait pu qu'il y a des parents
effectivement c'est pas arrivé ça je
suis content c'est pas arrivé mais ça
aurait pu mais moi je serais revenu à la
base de dire les trois grands bien avant
de mon plan de cours dans le programme
ministériel il y a trois grands
principes trois grands objectifs ok
c'est de
d'éduquer d'accord donc d'amener des
savoirs etc ça c'est clair que ce que en
tant que prof de musique vous attendez à
ce que les jeunes ils comprennent do ré
mi face à la citoyen
l'autre c'est de qualifier donc d'amener
des qualifications que ça effectivement
arrive peut-être un petit peu plus tard
dans le sens que tu vas obtenir ton
diplôme plus tard mais bon
mais ça se prépare toi aussi parce qu'il
faut leur montrer la possibilité de
choses vers lesquelles ils vont pouvoir
aller tu sais leur dire ça ça existe tu
peux faire ça si tu peux toutes les
possibilités que ça se prépare tout le
3e c'est de socialiser mais socialiser
les gens font comme à ben c'est à
prendre et avec tes amis tout ça non non
ça c'est une minuscule partie là ça
socialiser ça veut dire apprendre à
vivre en société ça veut dire
d'apprendre à vivre à comprendre ta
place dans la société comprendre tout ce
qui t'arrive de l'extérieur de la cité
c'est ça fait que le socialiser le moi
toutes mes discussions que j'ai eu sur
l'environnement sur l'alcool sur plein
d'autres choses aussi qui sont un peu en
dehors de mon curriculum juste de
musique mais ça rentre dans le socialisé
puis il manque énormément de socialiser
puis je suis content parce que grâce à
l'heure on peut amener ça aussi dans la
société là c'est beaucoup beaucoup ça
amène à réfléchir à plein d'autres
choses aussi à mettre à pousser des
choses plus loin à déstabiliser
certaines fois sur des idées préconçues
qu'on a ou sur plein plein de choses
alors là dans l'école ça peut servir à
ça aussi moi je m'en suis servi pour ça
et oui c'est clair que c'est en dehors
de mon
constaterait d'un prof de musique mais
c'est justement le problème c'est le
prof de musique qui enseigne la musique
c'est pas de français prof de science et
enseignation c'est propre qui leur
enseigne les choses qui vont vivre qui
leur enseigne la sexualité qui leur
enseigne le justement les discussions
sur l'alcool qui leur enseigne ça tombe
où ça tombe dans quel cas si tout le
monde est juste tiqué sur moi je dois
enseigner que ça
il faut il faut trouver des façons il
faut que je pense réfléchir assez façon
là de leur enseigner toutes ces choses
là aussi
je peux vraiment d'accord moi je te
posais la question parce que j'ai un ami
qui enseigne la physique au secondaire
puis c'est arrivé qui justement qui est
rentré dans ce genre de sujet là puis
après des choses qui étaient arrivées
puis il m'a dit que tout à fait dire par
la direction de
c'est comme ça pas de bon sens mais moi
je pense c'est notre rôle à ce moment-là
je suis désolé là mais premièrement
j'enseigne la physique combien d'élèves
dans ma classe vont réellement se servir
de mes enseignements en ce moment
et versus combien d'élèves vont je
l'espère se souvenir d'une discussion
qu'on a eu sur des sujets qui qui vont
les toucher c'est réellement puis tu es
la science là moi je suis désolé là il y
a de la science dans l'alcool dans la
composition de l'alcool puis tout ça
c'est de la science aussi je te la tu
peux il y a moyen de d'essayer de
bifurquer plusieurs maintenant je le
renseigne parfaitement la science je le
renseigne combien d'alcool dans tel doit
faire comment c'est fait l'alcool c'est
quoi les effets des
je sais pas scientifique
mais c'est quoi les effets de la faire
que c'est un euro-dépresseurs etc c'est
de la science là ça aussi là tu parles
tu parles de socialiser mais toi qu'on
met les les deux idées là ensemble en ce
moment dans le vivre en société une des
choses les plus primordiales c'est
l'esprit critique c'est avec à quel
point on est exposé à
n'importe quoi de la fausse information
n'importe quoi sur Internet et puis
d'avoir l'esprit critique pour être
capable de démêler ce qui est le vrai du
faux ça me semble être l'endroit parfait
un cours de physique pour apprendre ça
et puis socialiser en guillemets c'est
ça
peuvent contribuer à faire de toi une
meilleure personne pour
je l'espère en tout cas mais c'est ça
c'est qu'il faut pas oublier cet aspect
là dans dans l'éducation nos jeunes puis
l'aspect du chemin de socialisation de
vivre en société mais il est pas
toujours nécessairement inclus dans
toute parce qu'on justement on reste qui
faut que j'enseigne la musique mais je
reviens excuse
un autre sujet peut-être mais sur les
questions d'enseignement de la musique
justement la démo c'est un sujet qui
c'est super important dans la société la
partager puis pour le développement des
enfants aussi mais ces mettons quand
j'entends mettons du monde dire à quoi
ça sert pourquoi j'ai appris la flotte
aux primaire ça sert à quoi
parce que tu y crois c'est pourquoi
qu'on fait ça pourquoi on enseigne la
musique
premièrement c'est sûr que pour tout ce
qui est développement de la il y a plein
plein des études qui ont été faites puis
qui prouvent que tout ce qui est
développement quand les jeunes se
développent au niveau de la musique qui
se développent beaucoup beaucoup au
niveau des des langues aussi puis au
niveau de
plein d'autres formes d'apprentissage
aussi parce que la musique en soi c'est
une forme c'est une langue aussi c'est
un langage
mais clairement dis-moi je veux pas
nécessairement juste y aller vers la
flûte à bec c'est ça le problème c'est
que tout le monde retient juste la même
temps
c'est peut-être pas mais je l'amène de
façon différente j'estime l'amener de
façon plus bon puis je leur disais oui
on est rendu la flûte à bec en 4e
j'aimerais ça vous rendre un peu plus
autonome sur l'apprentissage a fait avec
vous le faites un petit peu par
vous-même on va faire un peu en classe
mais pour justement passer à d'autres
choses si je veux pas qu'on fasse juste
la flûte avec moi j'ai fait des projets
sur la musique au cinéma d'accord la
musique parce que la musique elle est
omniprésente au cinéma rattachée à aux
émotions j'arrive à aller voir un film
d'horreur de la musique était
mauditement important pour des rattacher
aux émotions bon mais ça
ça en est de la musique mais en même
temps je parle de cinéma puis je vois
peut-être je vais peut-être dans ma
classe le futur
on le sait pas mais c'est ça l'affaire
faut jamais oublier puis peut-être que
parce que il y a cet élément là qui
vient de se déclencher chez lui est
faite c'est donc un cool petit on
regarde des extraits de films où on
enlève la musique on se dit mais comment
s'est senti quand il y a pas de musique
on rajoute une musique différente on
change la musique etc on l'a créé on
crée une nouvelle musique sur cette
extrait là qu'on regarde ensemble
ben
ça en est de la musique mais c'est bien
plus
diversifié je veux dire que juste la
flûte à bec
oui c'est sûr il sort pas nécessairement
de là en étant des experts de la flûte à
bec mais en même temps comme je te dis
ils sortent en ayant vu plein d'autres
choses aussi c'est moi c'est ma vision
ça se peut que ça soit pas toutes les
profil c'est très correct aussi mais moi
ma vision c'est d'essayer de leur
montrer surtout au primaire bien entendu
le plus de choses possible pour les
intéresser à pour capter cet intérêt là
justement
un élément exactement plutôt que juste
sur l'apprentissage de la flûte à bien
c'est sûr de jouer d'un instrument mais
il y a moyen d'autre chose aussi tu sais
il y a moyen de me prouver que tu es un
bon musicien ou musicien ou tu as un peu
ça marche juste un intérêt méthode Tommy
du temps dans ton projet musical même si
tu es pas capable de jouer dans mes
façonner avec il y a moyen que je
t'évalue quand même sur ton aptitude à
interpréter de la musique même si tu le
fais pas nécessairement à travers juste
un instrument tu peux tu peux en
découvrir la musique tu peux la créer tu
peux aller dire au moins que si de
découvrir toutes les l'industrie mettons
du bruitage ça en est de la musique
aussi les bruits ça fait partie de ce
qu'on entend aussi tu sais
ça en est au cinéma de bruitage tout ça
c'est super important aussi de montrer
les pleins de vidéos qui montrent
les coulisses un peu du bruitage là on
pense que les bruits qu'ils enrichissent
au cinéma c'est ça mais c'est pas grave
fait après mais ça c'est super
intéressant même pour des adultes le
même pour des adultes mais encore plus
pour des jeunes qui font atteint la tête
en train de me dire que le bruit du du
vert d'eau qui se déplace sur la table
c'est pas le vrai bruit que j'entends
c'est un faux bruit qui a été recréé par
après oui c'est ça puis ça ça pourrait
être une job que tu fais aussi plus tard
ça t'intéresse c'est moi c'est ma vision
dans ça de d'essayer de justement
d'élargir puis pas juste cliquer sur la
flûte avec puis tu sais pas qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui va accrocher un jeune
tant que tu t'étends que tu le fais pas
parce que tout le monde en a toute une
histoire ou presque tout en tout cas la
plupart des gens ont une histoire de
comme amener il y a un prof qui a fait
de la faire puis moi ça a été le déclic
c'est vrai puis peu importe à quel
moment dans ton que ce soit primaire ou
secondaire au cégep où est-ce qu'il y a
un prof qui fait quelque chose puis toi
c'est sur ça que tu peins
que tu ratisses pas large puis ton offre
de qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
regardez qu'est-ce que vous apprenez et
pas le plus large possible
tu réduis les chances qu'il y a ce
moment-là pour quelqu'un je pense
exactement
[Rires]
la chose c'est mettons un jeune par les
difficultés mais qui traite vraiment
s'amuser quoi sur les anges en général
ça peut être la chose aussi qui
l'accroche qui donne une raison de
continuer à l'école pour cet exemple
absolument puis que peut-être ben lui il
va chanter au centre belle pendant que
tu vas
faire la comptabilité plus tard ça se
peut aussi il faut pas oublier qu'il y a
ça aussi puis faut pas dénigrer aucune
aucune forme de thé on est beaucoup axé
sur justement les études c'est vrai que
c'est important les études c'est
tellement important l'éducation mais
l'éducation a pu passer par plein
d'autres formes aussi éducation manuelle
ça en est une forme un petit peu à
prendre à faire des choses manuelles ou
t'as pas nécessairement toujours besoin
d'apprendre des cosinus puis des
tangentes puis des sinus
que tu faisais lors du compte puis mais
tu l'abordais en parlant de diversité
puis de dans de langues il va avoir
évidemment beaucoup plus de diversité
mais quelque chose que tu as mentionné
sur lequel je vais revenir c'est que tu
disais que
ça qu'avec l'immigration maintenant
qu'on qu'on
veut avoir plus d'immigration du moins
on veut réussir à mieux intégrer les
immigrants
mais c'était la première fois quand tu
le disais que je
considérais que l'intégration
ça se fait parental dans le sens où
quand les immigrants arrivent ici oui il
y a toute la question de la francisation
puis de comment les aider à bien
s'intégrer mais dans l'éducation des
jeunes il y a une part vraiment
importante de l'intégration future je
trouvais je trouvais le commentaire
vraiment impertinent en fait ben je le
pense aussi
c'est comment dire quand accueille
mettons-le sur soi quelqu'un chez vous
là ok ben
c'est chez moi je fais ce que je vais à
manger mais si la personne est
allergique là faut que tu sois concerne
il faut que toi tu t'adaptes aussi à une
personne qui vient chez vous pour notre
allergique au dessus
je fais un pâté correct à manger ça etc
bon tu végétarien faut que tu t'adaptes
aussi ça veut pas dire que la personne
peut arriver chez vous peut dire bah moi
je veux pas manger ça je vais pas manger
à la pâte à la faire faut que ça il y a
il faut mettre
un peu mais c'est le même principe oui
on accueille des gens
chez nous c'est pas réellement chez nous
on s'entend dans le sens qu'on a juste
nous tout ce qu'on a fait c'est naître
ici en fait on a rien fait c'est nos
parents qui l'ont fait on s'entend alors
il faut partir de ce principe là que moi
j'ai rien fait pour mériter de vivre au
Canada je suis né c'est tout j'habite au
Canada c'est tout ce que j'ai fait
mériter ça bref
ça en considération aussi je pense mais
quand tu as des gens qui arrivent ici
il y arrive ici souvent avec un bagages
puis qu'on connaît pas des choses qui
sont peut-être un peu différentes aussi
mais en bout de ligne je répète ce que
j'ai dit tantôt qui ont beaucoup plus de
similitudes avec ce que nous on veut ils
viennent pas ici pour ils viennent ici
parce qu'ils veulent la sécurité ils
veulent avoir une meilleure vie pour
leurs enfants souvent c'est des parents
qui amènent leur famille parce que ils
déménage pas nécessairement juste pour
eux des ménages pour leurs enfants
beaucoup aussi
ils veulent pas juste ils veulent pas
abuser de ce qu'on a ici ils veulent
juste être ils veulent ils veulent être
ils veulent ils ont les mêmes
préoccupations que nous être en sécurité
à être bien être aimé être accepté c'est
bon
évidemment avoir se sentir
utile aussi tu sais sentir que s'ils ont
des des connaissances qui peuvent les
mettre au bien de tous maintenant c'est
vrai que ça arrive que des fois il y a
des valeurs qui sont différentes c'est
nous ici je pense en tout cas que on a
de bonnes valeurs au Québec il faut
s'assurer que les gens qui arrivent
comprennent ces valeurs là donc c'est
pas évident parce que je sais que de
dire c'est quoi nos valeurs mais nos
valeurs à la base c'est parce que des
fois les gens mélangent mettons les
moyens d'arriver à ces valeurs là versus
les valeurs c'est les valeurs c'est à la
base c'est nous ici on a une valeur au
niveau d'acceptation au niveau
d'ouverture on a une valeur de de
respect mutuel aussi une valeur de de
d'égalité et d'équité tu sais c'est pas
parce que tu es un homme que tu es plus
hâte qu'une femme c'est pas parce que
etc ça c'est des choses qui sont à la
base c'est nos valeurs faut s'assurer
que ça je pense pas qu'il faut changer
nos valeurs par contre ça c'est quelque
chose à la base tu sais si toi tu es
végétarien tu reçois tes amis toi tu es
vraiment vraiment végétarien ça fait
partie de quelque chose qui est très on
va créer en toi tu reçois des amis chez
vous tu leur dis ben
moi je suis pas à l'aise que vous mangez
de la viande être capable de vous
adapter si c'est très très bon tu
comprends ce que je veux dire
c'est le même principe pour les gens qui
arrivent de l'extérieur des immigrants
qui viennent ici vivre ici il faut qu'on
s'assure qu'il comprenne c'est quoi nos
valeurs ici si tu arrives tu dis avec
des valeurs en disant ben les gays c'est
dégueulasse les femmes c'est moins que
des hommes ils devraient être au service
des hommes ça ça correspond pas à nos
valeurs ici on n'est pas juste dans
quelque chose que on peut on est capable
de faire des pas là dessus pour essayer
de t'accommander non pas là-dessus moi
je suis d'avis en tout cas sur ces
valeurs là ça ne devrait pas on devrait
pas faire de la commodation TA
commandement
mais une fois qu'on les accueille oui
c'est clair que les autres arrivent avec
leurs bagages avec leurs choses qui
qui sont en synchronisation en
synchronisation avec nos valeurs mais
qui sont peut-être un peu différentes
aussi qui arrivent qui prend un véhicule
différent pour arriver au même valeur tu
comprends ce que je veux dire c'est que
oui on a un travail à faire pour dire
ben je peux pas me permettre de juger
tout de suite du problème parce que je
tombe dans les préjugés je peux pas faut
que je prenne le temps faut que je
prenne faut que je garde en tête que
oui dans ma vie je vais voir des choses
qui sont très différentes mais que c'est
probablement des différences qui sont
relativement en surface parce que en
prenant le temps en retournant aux
valeurs je vais me rendre compte qu'ils
ont peut-être forcément les mêmes
valeurs
[Musique]
oui le changement il parle de
l'intérieur aussi puis je l'ai dit
en tout cas je pense on pourra pas
revenir en arrière puis dire non non on
revient juste à
c'était au Québec il faut que tu sois
blanc faut que tu sois même sûr que non
alors les jeunes les jeunes qui sont
dans les arts du compte que je fais ils
vont avoir ils vont être confrontés
à cette différence là c'est différente
là encore plus que nous alors il faut
les ouvrir déjà avec ça puis les juste
les préparer à dire ben ça se peut que
tu rencontres des gens qui sont
différentes toi ça se peut qu'il y ait
des gens qui mon Dieu qui des fois
parlent pas le français aussi bien que
toi on parle pas la même langue ça se
peut etc comme ça se peut que tu
rencontres aussi des gens qui
pas la même religion que toi qui sont
pas habillés comme toi qui porte les
cheveux rose qui porte des bijoux qui
portent les faux cils ben voilà mais
prends le temps c'est juste ça prend le
temps de de voir d'essayer de comprendre
ça se peut que vous entendiez pas
surtout c'est très correct tu as le
droit à ton opinion tu as le droit
mais un bout de ligne sur votre compte
que à la base il y a bien des choses qui
sont pareils finalement mais oui ces
enfants-là qui t'ont vu probablement
quand tu arrives quand tu es enfant je
veux dire tu étais écoute les émissions
pour enfants et tout sur des personnages
sur tout arrive il doit pas tomber de
leur chaise dans le sens qui doivent
de leur chance non bah c'est sûr qu'il
c'est sûr qu'en fait je pense c'est
surtout le côté impressionnant
les bijoux etc la robe c'est je pense
c'est ce côté-là puis aussi parce que
bon maintenant il y en a certains qui
m'ont ouvert à la télévision aussi dans
le dans l'émission pour enfants avec le
devoir en vrai c'est même les adultes
les tombes néanmés avec Glenn
j'ai un peu le truc c'est que on
s'imagine pas que ces personnes existent
en derrière la télévision même principe
avec les enfants aussi affectés
mais je m'assois je prends le temps de
leur dire bon qu'est-ce que je fais que
c'était rapide au bout de maximum trois
minutes donc parfaitement compris puis
on a passé un prochain appel puis là on
est les comptes on a du plaisir on fait
des activités musicales en fait toutes
sortes
il tombe pas en bas de la chaise non
mais c'est sûr que ça prend un petit
moment pour comprendre je suis content
parce que dans ce cadre là ils peuvent
le prendre le temps de comprendre
évidemment le problème c'est que si
justement
ceux qui sont voir les activités c'est
bien mais c'est ceux qui sont pas dans
les activités aussi que l'homme
malheureusement qu'il faudrait être
capable de riches
mais on reviendra à ça mais l'eau je
vais la aller avec cette idée là c'est
que peut-être que tu sais mettons les
enfants qui voient ils n'ont pas
conscience que nécessairement que ce qui
ont devant eux c'est un drive et une
drague et puis que
pitié tout ça puis peut-être que ils
vont juste passer un très bon moment
puis ça va être un bon souvenir mais
plus tard dans leur vie
il y a une drague comptait un compte
c'était dans l'iPhone ça peut
complètement changer la perception de
cette personne là va avoir des
différences dans le domaine sans s'en
rendre compte le moment que c'est donc
dès que c'est différent c'est exactement
ça c'est exactement ça c'est pile poil
dessus dis-moi ça m'a pris du temps à
savoir que Robin était là l'émission que
j'écoutais c'était deux filles
j'avais pas réalisé sur le coup mais
c'était cool j'ai mis l'émission puis
etc etc c'est le même principe aussi le
but c'est de comprendre que la personne
qui est devant toi elle va à votre faire
passer un bon moment à votre faire
passer avant peu importe le véhicule qui
a utilisé moi c'est la drague dans mon
cas oui je sais que c'est en dehors de
l'ordinaire c'est que c'est clair mais
peu importe le véhicule qu'elle utilise
elle va à votre faire passer un bon
moment tu vas avoir du fun puis c'est
tout
les enfants ne comprennent les adultes
des fois qui ne comprenaient
ça peut nous amener à parler de
ce qui s'est passé cet été dans le fond
parce que tu as trouvé une autre compte
en fait que tu vas faire
un tout petit peu au mois de juin je
faisais une heure du compte à Dorval
j'en faisais deux dans la même semaine
une première qui était plus privée pour
des enfants de d'une garderie là mais
trois classes de garderie qui venaient
donc été pas ouverte au public là c'est
comme un lundi matin juste parenthèse
combien de temps que tu fais ça depuis
2010 2016 la première fois que je l'ai
fait ouais ok exactement
et
donc c'est ça je l'ai fait l'activité à
pour les jeunes de la garderie dans une
bibliothèque mais la garderie la Une des
bibliothécaires après une photo le
mission les réseaux sociaux pour dire
hey barbada elle est venue aujourd'hui
pour l'heure du compte avec les autres
elle va revenir samedi mais là c'est
ouvert à tout le monde si vous voulez et
là c'est là qu'il y a une grosse
panique quand même une grosse polémique
là où là les gens se sont mis à part il
y a une vague de commentaires vague de
commentaires mais
des gens qui
sur les réseaux sociaux si jamais ou la
personne a pas été aux États-Unis en ce
moment en train de commenter surtout que
bon c'était dans un milieu c'était à
Dorval fait un peu plus anglophone aussi
parce que c'est pas la première heure du
compte que je faisais je l'ai dit fais
depuis 2005 donc je pense que le côté
anglophone a fait en sorte que peut-être
la nouvelle où ça c'est partager
beaucoup plus du côté anglophone aussi
puis pas au Québec
nécessairement Québec je veux dire
partout il y a peut-être des gens des
États-Unis là qui sont comme ça qui ont
commenté sur la photo alors ça fait un
peu boule de neige j'ai eu même des
menaces un peu plus sérieuses alors le
maire de Dorval a dit on va amener la
police mais on annule pas l'activité
elle aura lieu
la police était là quand je suis arrivée
de quand même des comptes qui
s'apprendent la police
ce serait je sais je sais et puis c'est
pour ça que moi je suis arrivé en disant
là il y aura pas un manifestant là c'est
pensez pas que les gens là qui sont sur
les réseaux réseaux sociaux ils vont ils
s'en permettent mais c'est comme il y a
des vidéos tiens je vous avais déjà qui
sont de chaque côté d'une grille puis
qui hurle que j'applin et puis ils sont
super méchants pour la grille rouge ils
sont face à face
des personnes sur les réseaux sociaux
bref
ça écrit gros comme le bras sur les
réseaux sociaux ça lance des menaces etc
mais je pense que notre devoir c'est
dire c'est pas vrai qu'on va céder à ça
à ce genre de bon etc et le maire de
Dorval fait parfaitement un très bon
travail selon moi on y va on y va de
l'avant avec l'activité etc mais c'est
sûr que ça le créé dans la tête des gens
quand même une certaine hop et en
passant il y a eu un manifestant mais
qui est arrivé avec son sa casquette
arc-en-ciel son drone arc-en-ciel
pour l'activité justement interviewé
d'ailleurs pour son balado bon bref
mais ça fait en sorte qu'effectivement
il y a peut-être des gens qui avaient
prévu l'activité qui est là on vu la
polémique
des inquiétudes plus que de la peur mais
des inquiétudes alors quand à la
bibliothèque de Saint-Laurent les
bibliothécaires qui m'avaient été prévu
au mois de novembre mais qui avait prévu
ça depuis je pense février je regarde le
courriel me semble février que j'aimais
ça ils ont présenté aux élus municipaux
leur programmation c'est une façon de
faire c'est par principe mais les
illumini Municipaux ont rien à dire sur
la première mission c'est les
bibliothécaires qui décident etc là les
illumini Municipaux s'en sont bien
libres sont dehors barbada on est pas
sûr
ça s'est passé le quelques semaines il
était un peu frileuse on va revenir au
prochain conseil municipal on va
argenter etc au conseil municipal
suivant et on décidé d'annuler
l'activité là évidemment les
bibliothécaires ils se font annuler leur
programmation
on veut des activités qui font la
promotion de l'ouverture de la
différence etc c'est ça qu'on mette
l'avant dans nos bibliothèques dans
notre programmation puis vous allez des
annuler nos activités
dans ce coin-là et
une des bibliothécaires
avec raison dans un sens et aller en
parler aux médias avec moi j'ai appris
ça des médias Mario Gérard qui m'écrit
sur Facebook qui me dit ah salut
j'aimerais te parler pour l'annulation
d'activité moi j'ai fait bien rire
c'est lui qui me l'apprend donc c'est
moi je suis frustré là-dedans évidemment
encore plus de pas être au courant
j'ai des entrevues à faire et puis j'ai
même pas courant de la situation alors
moi tu penses bien que je prends le
téléphone je fais des appels auprès des
bibliothécaires je parle à la chef de
division des bibliothèques puis tout ça
la ville de Saint-Laurent m'explique la
situation je dis mais
pourquoi vous m'avez pas appelé pourquoi
on sait pas parler pourquoi je suis pas
allé les rencontrer vous étiez j'aurais
compris c'est l'activité était la
semaine prochaine on prend la décision
un peu rapidement on décide de reporter
pas de problème le reporter plutôt
qu'annuler maintenant
l'activité qui est dans 4 mois 5 mois
avant même qu'on puisse s'asseoir
exactement exactement
je pense que le fait qu'elle en a parlé
dans les médias a fait réagir les gens
de Saint-Laurent les élus municipaux je
pense à c'est devenu plus gros qui qui
auraient voulu définitivement moi je
trouve que c'est devenu plus gros
j'aurais voulu parce que à nouveau je
répète tout ça ça aurait pu être réglé
si on s'était juste parlé si vous
m'aviez juste dit
ils sont pas sûr tu peux te souvenir les
convaincre
[Musique]
pas de problème effectivement
c'est exactement ça que j'ai fait ils
m'ont dit ok ils vont finalement ils ont
accepté de te promet de rencontrer le
premier août dont le coïncidence au
début de la semaine de la fierté mais
rien mais bon
accepter les rencontrer 75 minutes plus
tard il était comme merci de nous avoir
rencontré super cool on sait ce que tu
veux faire on comprend ce que tu veux
faire avec les jeunes on remet
l'activité au programme on essaie le
drapeau guide devant la minute devant la
mairie
devant la mairie de Saint-Laurent puis
on remet l'activité au programme puis là
ben voilà fait embout de ligne tout ça
pour dire que il faut se parler
dans une grosse tempête dans un verre
d'eau potentiellement ça l'aurait été
en fait oui c'est une grosse tempête
dans un verre d'eau puis tempête que
clairement pu être évité comme bien des
situations dans la vie où on peut se
parler puis ça ça m'a aussi ça m'a aussi
fait prendre conscience du pouvoir des
médias puis de faire attention aussi par
exemple les médias sont jeunes pas de
mauvaises intentions me dire mais parce
qu'une fois que c'est dans les médias là
ça sort puis là les gens vont prendre
juste des brides d'informations et là
c'est là que c'est très très dangereux
j'ai des gens qui m'accordait dans la
rue qui était pour le désactiver que je
fais là je les voyais dans le village
qui était super cool ce que tu fais mais
on est donc triste de toutes les
annulations toutes les annulations
tu peux faire une espèce de train ni de
poudre de route à pull contrôle c'est ça
qui est très très
pernicieux puis dangereux je dirais à la
limite aussi quand on y va publiquement
avec surtout avec les réseaux sociaux
tout ce qui est médias aussi j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est une boîte de
Pandore qu'on peut plus refermer
la
frivolité des médias tu sais parce que
là c'est puis on en parle on en a parlé
même que ça fait longtemps qu'on avait
pas parlé sur le Podcast de ça mais puis
là c'est encore pire que qu'on en
parlait au sens où
il y a tellement une course à avoir le
scoop et le gros titre puis le potin en
premier qu'il y a même pu la du
diligence du journaliste d'essayer de
comprendre c'est quoi l'histoire tu sais
moi ça m'est arrivé d'avoir des articles
repartagés qui me concernaient de
journalistes qui avaient
aucune idée l'histoire quand tu lis le
truc tu fais tu as même pas pris la
peine de lire le document duquel tu
parles et puis mais j'ai l'impression
que c'est ça pour tout le monde c'est
ton histoire là c'est c'est précisément
ça c'est quelqu'un qui a pris l'article
mon niveau là ça part ça part en couille
dessus
de loin de la vraie affaire
mais c'est ça fait très attention à tout
ce qui est tout ce qui est public tout
ce qui est réseaux sociaux tout ce qui
gagne un bon pouvoir aux médias aussi
puis ça je moi je serais pas d'avis de
sport à la danse Trump
ça prend les médias parce que souvent
c'est grâce aux médias qui révèlent
certaines choses que le public c'est pas
ça prend ça prend des journalistes
informés qui prennent qui font ces
enquêtes-là qui font etc etc et cetera
mais justement aussi le le la
contrepartie c'est que une fois que ça
sort après ça on prend juste des
informations on prend juste des petites
affaires c'est une histoire que on peut
expliquer en en 20 minutes et
t'expliquer et raccourcis en un texte
que les gens prennent 4 minutes allez
puis après ça ira Courcelles de 30
secondes pendant le Bullet
en manque des buts là on a vraiment que
c'est très très
c'est la première fois dans ma vie que
je me confrontais un peu à ça que
j'étais dans cette situation là mais en
même temps je pense que je l'avais
peut-être lancé un peu dans l'univers
parce que
longtemps quand j'enseignais aussi puis
là en ce moment je suis en pause
d'enseignement évidemment là depuis un
an et demi pour concentrer sur la depuis
la situation je vous ai expliqué aussi
on peut voulu m'accorder un congé sans
solde mais bref
quand j'enseignais tout ça c'est arrivé
souvent ou des gens me demandaient tout
de suite mettons des réactions négatives
de parents toutes sortes c'est comme
jamais si jamais arrivé mais j'aimerais
sûre que ça arrive j'aimerais ça qu'un
parent moi j'ai vu que vous faites la
drague je veux pas que vous enseigner à
mon fils on a fait parce que ça ça me
donnerait l'occasion de leur dire on va
s'asseoir on va prendre le temps je vais
vous expliquer qu'est-ce que c'est la
drague puis dites-moi c'est quand la
dernière fois que vous avez un show de
drague on était jamais allé revoir ok
c'est quand la dernière mettons mettant
quelqu'un qui me dit oui wesh alors
c'est où au cabernado c'est qui qui est
au camerano bah des adultes ah c'est pas
pareil on est avec des enfants pas la
même chose me semble
juste avoir ce j'ai jamais eu l'occasion
et j'ai jamais eu un seul parent qui m'a
dit négativement que quoi que ce soit
vous ou du moins ça s'est jamais rendu à
mes oreilles peut-être la direction fait
un bon travail à dire à amortir le choc
sans que ça se rende à moi parfait mais
moi ça s'est jamais rendu à moi mais là
peut-être que justement la force de
répéter cette affaire-là
dire j'aimerais ça qu'il y a des parents
que j'aimerais ça mais c'est devenu ce
que c'est devenu aujourd'hui avec
l'histoire cet été mais à nouveau je
vois le positif là-dedans j'ai eu
l'occasion de la probablement ça a été
de la bonne très bonne publicité parce
que jamais autant de personnes qui m'ont
appelé j'ai dit j'en fais une ce matin
dans une garderie en fait dans toutes
les semaines dans des bibliothèques des
des théâtres etc etc bon alors c'est
très très positif mais
ça m'a aussi donné l'opportunité
d'expliquer qu'est-ce que je faisais
réellement ça aussi donné l'opportunité
à des même des gens qui sont venus dans
les articles qui en ont parlé après dans
les médias dont on parlait dans les
journaux le sac de Tchip entre autres
qui qui a dit voici ce que vous allez
voir quand vous allez venir à l'heure du
compte avec barbada qui détaillait
est-ce que ça se passait puis comment ça
se passe réellement parce que
malheureusement les gens qui se
permettent de critiquer ils sont jamais
venus puis je peux comprendre jusqu'à un
certain point que si tu te bases sur ce
que tu poids à la télé sur les choses
dragues si tu vois si tu passes sur ce
que tu vois dans des bars adultes etc
c'est sûr que si tu fais un amalgame ah
ben ça c'est la drague c'est que il y a
aucun bon mais là on est d'ailleurs puis
c'est pas juste ça c'est moi je suis
prof de musique je le sais comment
interagir avec des gens je le sais qu'un
enfant qui est qui arrive puis qui rit
il rit pas de moi c'est pas méchant mais
c'est un adulte que jamais travaillé
avec des enfants il sait pas il va tout
de suite se braquer en disant tu cries
non il comprend pas c'est juste ça que
sa façon de l'exprimer c'est à travers
le rire c'est juste il est pas mal
intentionné là il est juste il comprend
pas ce qu'il voit en ce moment puis lui
sa façon de d'enlever la pression c'est
de rire ben c'est ça alors
moi je le sais je le comprends ben des
dragues que j'enverrai jamais me
remplacer dans une heure du congre
non plus
mais là c'est un podcast où je sais que
c'est majoritairement des adultes toi
tout le moins des jeunes adultes
adolescents qui vont l'écouter c'est ça
qu'on est capable il faut que les gens
comprennent ça aussi dans ça mais comme
dans bien d'autres situations que tu as
comme il y a une incompréhension il y a
une différence où il y a une situation
puis écoute on en a parlé quand je
lisais l'article qui qui relayait
justement ce qui s'était passé
peut-être la demande on peut dessus
parler j'étais comme ça
la bonne chose à faire déjà au lieu de
juste comme
c'est juste ça puis à nouveau ça aurait
pu être fait pas publiquement pendant
les médias ça peut être fait à huis clos
dans la salle du conseil municipal comme
ce qui est arrivé mais bien avant ça
aurait pu arriver tout avant la fin
médiatique parce que je sais que s'il y
avait pris le temps de me rencontrer
j'aurais dit exactement les mêmes choses
que j'ai dit ce serait parlé puis
j'aurais répondu à leur inquiétude aussi
leur dire parce que ça c'était parmi les
inquiétudes aussi mais si on a des gens
qui réagissent comme à Dorval et on
réagit qu'est-ce qu'on fait on leur
répond quoi mais vous leur répondez que
premièrement venez voir l'activité ou
vous les diriger vers vers moi me faire
plaisir aussi de leur répondre tu sais
ouvrir mon agent peu importe mais où
vous les diriger vers l'émission pour
enfants pour leur montrer c'est quoi
leur montrer que ça peut être adapté
pour des enfants vous les dirigez vers
moi je ne demande pas aux gens d'aimer
la drague quand je leur dis découvrez la
neige lamente pas des messages je leur
dis je demande de comprendre pour
respecter ça et ça devient comprendre
exactement c'est le respect bien avant
d'aimer de droite d'aimer ou pas aimer
mais il faut que tu respectes ça c'est
la même chose pour bien des affaires
aussi tu sais les amis qui sont
chasseurs d'envie de moi dans la vie là
justement je suis un peu végétarienne
c'est bon
on peut l'imaginer
bref
des amis
mais bref les amis qui sont chasseurs
qui font la chasse moi je comprends je
comprends pas mais je comme ça
mais je me suis assis avec un d'entre
eux pour dire c'est quoi qu'est-ce que
tu fais là tu t'amuses tuer des animaux
pour le plaisir les femmes bien sûr que
non écoute j'ai de la viande pendant
8 9 mois après ça
je m'assure
que le physique j'utilise
ok j'en ferai jamais ça là pas du tout
j'aime pas la charge j'aime toujours pas
la chasse mais je suis capable de
comprendre c'est quoi puis te respecter
pourquoi tu fais ça
puis finalement de rencontre qu'il y a
peut-être certaines valeurs aussi c'est
moi beaucoup en mettant par rapport à
l'environnement ben finalement c'est
peut-être plus local de manger une
viande qui est dans ta cour arrière que
de la farnière de Chine
dans la nature plutôt que dans un voilà
exactement
j'ai toujours dit ça depuis que je suis
végan que j'ai pas mal plus de en commun
avec les chasseurs qu'avec les gens qui
achètent leur bouffe à l'épicerie là
c'est en tant que vegan parce que j'ai
des amis chasseurs j'en ai plein
d'autres comme tu dis il tue une fois la
seule viande qui mange de l'année au
complet c'est la viande qui ont tué non
seulement il la mange mais il a Gaspé
probablement beaucoup moins de risques
ils ont eu à travailler pour c'est un
steak qui t'arrive là tu as pas idée
toute la piste mais c'est plein d'autres
hein quantité de gaspillage alimentaire
qu'on fait parce qu'on a pas conscience
de tout le chemin que cette nourriture
là en fait avant d'arriver dans notre
assiette si on avait mis les phares de
travailler pour l'avoir cette nourriture
là haut que évidemment l'argent mais je
parle mais qu'on avait mis l'effort de
de la chasser justement ou de toute la
cultiver mettons etc de garantie qu'on a
caspiré beaucoup moins c'est clair
parce que d'habitude les drag queen on
dit qu'on avait quand même parce qu'on
mange juste des graines ça c'est
moi je mange juste des grosses du gazon
ce qu'on dit ok
mais est-ce que tu viens de dire là
parce que là on est parti sur la
tangente vegan non mais
juste de s'asseoir puis de parler puis
c'est
on a 99% en commun avec tout le monde
autour de nous le dit souvent
on parle c'est tellement
la solution a beaucoup de mots de notre
époque si Will Smith était juste monté
ça puis avait pris le micro puis avait
dit i Christmas
la raison pour laquelle a pas ses
cheveux c'est parce qu'elle souffre de
telles maladies tout ça ça aurait fait
un gros malaise je vous garantis tout le
monde aurait fait au shit mais je peux
te garantir que lui il aurait pu drap
demain qu'après retourner s'asseoir puis
il y aurait probablement été même
applaude
exactement et c'est ça parlez-vous
parlons-nous c'est juste ça on a la
chance de pouvoir le faire on a des mots
utilisant les c'est plus je comprends un
peu plus de temps c'est sûr mais c'est
juste ça c'est pour plein de domaines
pas juste pour la drague pas juste pour
les heures du compte bien loin c'est
dans des périodes un peu de
conflit mais un peu plus conflictuel
comme des élections où là justement on
débats beaucoup d'idées on a
l'impression qu'on se parle beaucoup
mais des fois on s'écoute pas beaucoup
hein
puis bon quand on sait aussi en plus les
taux de pourcentages de participation
qui sont vraiment pas si élevés que ça
en bowling un petit peu dire ouais c'est
pas tout le monde qui se parle c'est pas
tout le monde qui sait parler pendant un
fait on ressent une campagne électorale
avec l'impression qu'on est vraiment
loin sur bien des affaires sur bien des
enjeux mais quand on prend le temps de
se parler finalement on réalise que
c'est peut-être pas si différent oui les
véhicules pour on veut arriver à la même
chose mais les véhicules sont peut-être
pas tout à fait pareil c'est vrai
mais c'est ça faut juste prendre le
temps pour ceux qu'on parle de la
culture drague en général c'est parce
qu'on dirait tout à fait quand même
longtemps
on dirait que dans les dernières années
il y a comme une explosion ce que tu es
moins plus dans le mainstream des
dragues au Québec j'imagine que tu l'as
remarqué et puis je veux dire pour qu'on
invite mais en fait ce qui est arrivé
c'est que justement on a sorti les
dragues des cabarets puis la façon on
amenait les dragues chez les gens la
façon encore aujourd'hui de faire ça
c'est la télévision ok on dit bon il y a
d'autres médiums maintenant aussi là
évidemment les podcasts c'est une façon
aussi de mais en même temps
certaines fois
il reste encore beaucoup beaucoup la
télévision parce que t'as pas déplacé tu
rentres littéralement chez les gens à
travers la télévision alors la
télévision entre autres avec des
documentaires comme il le jour elle de
nuit sur ARTV qui était diffusé en 2017
mais aussi évidemment dry grace
et éventuellement Canada
sont rentrés chez les gens et là les
gens ont compris un peu plus c'est quoi
tout le monde qui aime à nouveau c'est
très correct on comprend ça mais il
reste que les gens ont vu de plus en
plus alors oui c'est devenu beaucoup
plus mainstream grâce à la télévision
grâce à vos post Drag Race grâce à
d'autres émissions aussi puis plus
plus ça va plus effectivement les gens
réalisent que c'est pas toutes les
dragues qui sont parfaites dans certains
contextes télévisuels par exemple mais
que il y en a des dragues faut juste
fouiller un peu qui amener une drague
dans une émission de télé ou dans un
podcast ou dans dernières années mission
de radio ou dans peu importe ça peut
être vraiment le fun puis vraiment très
papi vraiment puis que ces personnes là
ces artistes là parce que c'est des
artistes ont des choses à dire aussi
j'ai vu des émissions où tu as une
tablée d'artistes qui se permettent de
commenter sur toutes sortes de choses
qui sont absolument pas de leur domaine
puis on accorde de l'importance à
l'heure opinion juste parce qu'ils sont
faits juste parce que j'ai connu il doit
connaître ça mais papa ça se peut qu'il
connaît il parle aucunement en
connaissance de cause
sont capables de le faire pourquoi pas
faire venir des drag queen aussi
peut-être tu comprends en fait bref oui
c'est beaucoup plus mainstream et je
suis extrêmement content de ça il y a
des dragues qui ont évidemment pavé le
chemin à ce qu'on se rende là les Mado
les guildas aussi qui étaient bon mais
il reste que là maintenant grâce à la
télévision là ça c'est vraiment
concrétisé puis les gens sont voix des
dragues partout tu sais je dis partout
mais faut pas dire partout parce que ça
c'est la même chose il y a des gens qui
sont dans le drogue sont rendus partout
hey vu ce que je te fasse la liste des
missions que tu peux écouter il y a pas
de drague garantir qu'il va en avoir pas
mal plus long tu vois tu as pas tu as
pas toutes de passer de toute une vie
pour écouter toutes les émissions en ce
moment où il y a pas de travail avec du
monde qui vivent leur vie sans jamais
voir de drague mais oui puis malgré tout
ça moi je considère en ce moment je suis
comme la quatrième drague la plus
populaire au Québec après ma dose et
Michel Richard puis euh mais là il y a
Gisèle qui a gagné
malgré tout des fois je vais à la 7 île
avec un contrat pour un des syndicats
là-bas puis
[Musique]
faire plus de gens vont réaliser que
c'est le fun c'est tripant autant
d'aller voir des choses
autant de d'aller voir un mettons un
spectacle jeunesse ou un spectacle
familial aussi parce qu'il y en a des
spectacles qui sont parfaitement adaptés
pour toutes les familles spectacle de
drague
autant de regarder l'émission jeunesse
que regarder Rita qui commente qui s'est
chanter ou peu importe voilà voilà
je suis très content très content de la
vague qui se produit en ce moment
j'espère juste que ce sera pas
temporaire j'espère juste que ce sera
pas comme des fois quand les choses
montent vite ça redescend vite aussi
avec ça je suis magnifique un petit peu
de ça je m'assure je veux qu'on s'assure
d'avoir quand même une qualité dans ce
qu'on offre puis dans ce qu'on parce
qu'il suffirait juste d'un incident
malheureux qui fait ces boules de neige
puis que c'est une drague qui est à la
mauvaise place qui dit la mauvaise chose
pour que finalement toute sa ramasse à
s'écrouler puis toutes les progrès qui a
été fait dans l'avancement de de de de
les mentalités que ça s'effondre juste à
cause d'une personne qui est à mauvaise
place une drague qui malheureusement a
dit quelque chose d'un peu assez fait de
dire je sais pas un producteur qui ça
nous prend des dragues parfait ouais
mais attention est-ce que ça te tremble
vraiment des dragues ou est-ce que tu
veux vraiment une drague juste pour
parce que ça tu dis assez c'est in c'est
ça qu'il faut en ce moment ou si c'est
parce que tu as réellement penser un
concept pour qu'une drague soit là c'est
pour que ça soit adapté pour une drague
aussi ça c'est la même chose aussi tu
sais quand on parle d'inclusion
il y a beaucoup de des fois des
compagnies ou des des
campings bref beaucoup de situations où
on sent que
les gens veulent être inclusifs fait
qu'ils disent on va faire venir des
dragues ouais mais est-ce que ce que tu
veux faire est adapté pour une drague tu
sais où tu le fais juste parce que ça va
donner une bonne image puis ben c'est le
fun c'est que ça va bien marcher
peut-être que ça pourrait être une
personne issue de la communauté LGBTQ 2
+ mais
pas une règle nécessairement ça pourrait
aussi ça ça serait de l'inclusion aussi
comme des fois je donne un exemple une
publicité que j'ai faite il y a
certaines publicités où tu vas voir
ils vont mettre de tout si tu vas voir
des gens tu vas voir des ils vont ils
vont tout cocher les causes pour dire à
qui on les a toutes mis parfait c'est
comme un gros amalgame où tu vas avoir
plein de gens qui sont mais il y a pas
de concept réellement adapté pour
chacune de ces personnes là alors que
exemple d'autres publicités dont une que
j'ai faite ou le concept s'éteindre
fallait que ça soit une drive le concept
était bâti était pensé pour que ce soit
une drague qui vendent visite pour faire
de peu pour viser j'en faisais une autre
mais c'est c'est ça c'était pensé il
fait que ça ça montre que c'est pas
juste un souci de ton on a oublié
d'inclure du monde puis là on essaie de
cacher les cases la dernière minute fait
de nous venir une drague une personne
noire asiatique puis un WAGO en pour
qu'on pour qu'on vous on voit qu'on est
inclusif ou
afficher notre du drapeau gay pendant le
mois de la fiert pendant la semaine la
fierté pour être sûr que tout le monde
voit qu'on est inclusif mais on fait
fucker le rien de l'année c'est ça la
réelle inclusion faut qu'elle pense dans
ses processus là de penser des des
concepts pour que ça soit adapté pour
des dragues mais de dire aussi ben nous
notre publicité je ne sais même un
exemple publicité mais ça va être un
couple gay ou ça va être un couple de
lesbienne ça va être mais pas juste on
va voir un gain lesbienne pour avoir
plein d'autres couples on va noter des
fois dire on est capable de dire ben
notre publicité même si c'est un couple
de lesbienne elle va parler à tout le
monde quand même comprendre
puis elle sera pas juste là pendant la
semaine de la fierté donc on va la faire
à l'année on va faire ça peut être vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire c'est ça
aussi le principe qu'il faut faire très
attention que j'espère que les gens vont
comprendre les entreprises vont
comprendre les médias vont comprendre
pour être sûr que cette belle vague là
tu dois dire on veut une drague c'est un
peu dire comme ben c'est toute la même
affaire pour vous en prendre une de la
gagne c'est parce que exactement
différent c'est pas exactement comme
ça
c'est peut-être pas porté
l'humoriste c'est qui et puis même chose
des fois pour des parties aussi là des
fois il y a des gens qui font et on veut
une dragonne ok mais c'est quoi ton
parti là finalement en parlant avec eux
je connais c'est pas adapté du tout là
c'est pas c'est pas c'est quoi une un
shoot drague
c'est pas ça que ça te prend ça se peut
aussi là mais malheureusement des fois
il y a des gens qui vont dire ça nous
prend une drague qui vont aller bouquer
la première venue puis ça se passera
peut-être pas nécessairement super bien
parce qu'à nouveau c'est pas adapté pour
ça c'est pas le bon contexte puis ben
c'est ça ils vont dire ouais finalement
on n'est pas trop sûr des dragues ça va
donner mauvais faut faire attention
c'est pour ça je dis des fois quand ça
monte vite ça redescend vite je veux pas
que ça fasse tu sais je veux qu'on
installe des bases solides pour que tout
le monde comprenne c'est quoi l'art de
la drague vous comprenez aussi que il y
a pas juste de Drag Queen parce que à la
limite ça peut plus mettre misogyne
parce qu'on exclut beaucoup de femmes
qui font l'art de la drague les femmes
qui font des choses drag queen les
femmes qui font des choses de drague
King puis des femmes ou même des
personnes non binaires aussi qui jouent
beaucoup sur la fluidité de genre mais
qui pratiquent lors de la drague et qui
peuvent parfaitement être super le fun
sur une émission télé ou sur un podcast
ou ce whatever c'est un balado
alors je pense que c'est important de de
mettre ces bases solides là pour que
pour pas que ça fasse juste comme un une
vague ça redescende tout de suite après
il faut que les gens comprennent c'est
quoi mais il faut que les gens
s'intéressent à ça aussi pour essayer je
suis super content de faire partie de
cette belle vague là tellement content
mais il y en a plein d'autres aussi ça
me dérange pas des fois de donner ma
place aussi à d'autres dans un contexte
qui est adapté je répète des fois
j'enverrai pas n'importe quel drague me
faire me remplacer sur une heure du
compte mais si moi je peux pas dis pas
non à ton heure du compte fait la quand
même mais je veux référer vers d'autres
personnes qui vont te faire passer qui
vont faire une belle activité aussi
comme moi tu sais c'est ça qu'il faut
prendre en compte pour quelqu'un mettons
qui connaît moins l'or de la drague
maintenant tu dirais que c'est quoi les
espèces de
d'éléments fondateurs qui font d'une
drague une drague attends c'est quoi le
principe de base là c'est que c'est une
forme d'art qui combine plein d'autres
formes d'or ok mais à différents niveaux
ok fait que chaque drague va chercher sa
forme d'or qui est sa spécialité ou
qu'elle aime mieux qu'il ou elle est
mieux mais va quand même faire des
enfants j'inclus là-dedans le chant même
si on chante pas avec notre
prévoyez-vous on fait semblant de
chanter quand on fait des performances
la danse
le théâtre parce que c'est un personnage
de théâtre aujourd'hui le en ce moment
c'est sûr que c'est barbadoc vous voyez
et je suis très belle en passant à les
voir si vous écoutez sur un audio aller
sur Youtube
mais bref histoire que j'ai pas pris la
peine que ça va la famille
bref
il faut oui c'est ça théâtre toute
l'aspect visuel maquillage costume etc
forcément parce que honnêtement moi j'ai
des des coiffures qui sont réellement
des pièces des œuvres d'art celle-là
elle fone et c'est pas cool mais j'en ai
que c'est des heures et des heures de
travail qui sont sur ma tête j'ai
vraiment l'impression de porter une
oeuvre d'art sur du travail que le poste
c'est vous-même qui fabriquez très
souvent très souvent effectivement et
donc la drague ça combine toutes ces
formes d'arts
et oui parce que je considère l'humour
comme une forme d'art aussi tout à fait
alors tout ça la musique lâchant la
danse l'humour le théâtre toutes les
épées visuels le maquillage à coiffer la
mode ben c'est réuni dans les spectacles
de drague dans la drague lors de la
drague chaque personne décide qu'est-ce
qui prend il y en a que la spécialité là
c'est le maquillage moi ça jamais été ma
force je le sais je maquillage qui est
correct je l'ai
un peu pour finir j'ai eu des cours un
peu récemment là j'ai pris un atelier
avec un ami puis il m'a donné des petits
trucs que je faisais pas correct puis là
si je trouve mais c'est pas ma force je
le sais je le sais ce sera jamais ça
puis c'est correct je ferai jamais des
photos moi je suis pas une drague
Instagram c'est par contre va te faire
passer un méchant belveillé pour se
faire rire je vais faire des personnages
je vais faire des numéros de comédie ça
c'est ma force il y en a qui dansent
comme ça là aucun bon sang qui font des
splits j'en ai vu des dragues c'est des
autobus à deux étages bon à Miami il y a
des choses qui se passe beaucoup comme
la rue ça fait des dragons puis il y a
la rue qui passe puis la drague là à
part du deuxième étage de l'autobus
asgaroche à Bob qui a finalement
je me dis ça c'est sa force avec la
drague c'est tout ça maintenant comme je
dis comme il y a plein de niveaux les
gens peuvent décider quel niveau le plus
bien sûr il y a toute l'aspect des looks
mais il y a beaucoup plus que ça aussi
et je pense que c'est pour ça que c'est
important de prendre le temps d'aller
voir des choses dragues ou juste de
prendre le temps de découvrir un peu les
différents CD il y en a qui vont que tu
vas aimer d'autres que tu aimeras pas du
tout un peu comme n'importe quoi
des gens qui qui aiment pas le Country
mais des gens etc
il y a des styles de Drag que tu
aimerais pas d'autre que tu vas aimer
mais c'est extrêmement varié c'est
extrêmement varié fait que il y a pas un
modèle de drague et à nouveau il y a
encore des gens qui disent que les
dragues c'est des hommes qui s'habillent
enfant mais justement c'est beaucoup
plus que ça parce que c'est premièrement
pas juste des hommes c'est des femmes et
des personnes non binaires
vastes spectre de personnes qui
pratiquent lors de la drague et chaque
drague
il y a que de gens qui font la drague
aussi même deux chanteurs country font
pas la même style de chanson country ça
va être deux chanteurs ou chanteuses
country mais ils vont le faire chacun
leur façon puis ils vont amener une
couleur différente à leur or tu sais
c'est le même principe pour la drague
mais on est dans le divertissement dans
le plaisir mais on est aussi dans
quelque chose de d'un peu plus engagé
aussi la drague ça a commencé beaucoup
avec les les revendications plus
politiques pour la communauté de s.gbtq
plus c'était vraiment
les les porte-parole un peu de ces
communautés là les marchés Johnson qui
était une porte étendard de Tibo here is
tweet toutes les manifestations à ce
tournoi puis ces choses-là qui sont
passées beaucoup aux États-Unis mais
c'était un peu plus politique tu sais
évidemment aujourd'hui avec l'avancement
des droits des communautés
certainement on n'est plus dans des
revendications aussi ont été sans plus
dans les rues pour il y a encore des des
la fierté encore des célébrations de la
fierté mais justement on est plus dans
les célébrations que dans les
revendications nécessairement
mais il y a encore je pense l'aspect
politique de ça je pense qu'elle doit
rester quand même un peu aussi ne
serait-ce que bon on a parlé tantôt les
arts du compte et tout ça l'avancement
de certaines mentalités puis de faire
l'art je l'ai dit l'or en général ça
sert à ça aussi à confronter certaines
choses qu'on fait depuis longtemps et
puis qu'on disait si tu veux vraiment la
bonne chose à faire si tu veux vraiment
la bonne ça sert à confronter un peu là
aussi fait que moi j'utilise la drague
pour ça pour passer un message pour
avoir une vitrine pour avoir un micro
pour passer ses messages là mais aussi
pour divertir puis de faire passer une
belle soirée et puis de faire taper ses
cuisses par la sculptury puis faire en
sorte que du moins je laisse faire
probablement si tu as déjà choisi de te
déplacer jusqu'à un cabaret ou un
spectacle ou d'une miroir un spectacle
déjà c'est un bel et très
particulière mais d'après de te faire
passer de ce que c'est que je connais
c'est à les bras croisés à stapser
cuisses c'est le fun j'en ai eu des
comme ça j'en ai vu des gens comme ça
puis après ça mais j'ai l'impression de
dire ok j'ai fait ma job travaille
accompli travaille accompli cochez
balancé où est-ce que les gens peuvent
te suivre qu'est-ce que ça va bien pour
toi ben écoute j'essaye j'essaye de
partir un compte omnifère en ce moment
les gens peuvent aller voir mais on est
fan dans un vraiment juste un S c'est ma
mère donc
[Rires]
non mon site internet pardon.ca
et sinon ben j'ai pas très Instagram là
je l'ai dit mais bon mais des photos de
faire la même là-dessus mais beaucoup
mon site internet beaucoup les choses
passent beaucoup par là mon calendrier
de spectacle aussi quand même assez
rempli je vous cacherai pas là il y en a
un shopping berge dans cette tant mieux
mais là je m'en vais faire une sieste
c'est ça
maquiller parce que j'ai un autre
spectacle ce soir on fait qu'on va
dormir comme un vampire
[Rires]
merci beaucoup d'être
très très plaisir ça fait un cinéma